CRUSEN
CLAIDI
LAEDBROAD USR THIN
E
INFORMATION ABOU
HE A TREAT
ONMINENT
RT KENNE
THGHADE HEADLINES K,
O TALK ABOUT
IT, AS "THE WAIN THI
JOINING ME IS
TALK ABOUT IT,NT OF WS
ORH HIS PRAYSTAR, WHAT
TELLING VIEWERS ON C>> TRUE.
MARCUSAMS THE HEAD OOF THE LST
PHARMAHEE  WERE ALTERNRE LY B
.
HE FELT HE WAS GIVEN THEABOUT V-
HAVEHELOT OF VACCINE
OBRDCOR WEL>>N SOME
LAMB DID TINDCASTER ERICMETAXAS.
OUSO GURUS
OANTI-MAS
TH, ESPECIALLY
EVANGELICA THE
PACHURCHES.IT'S SHUT THEM DN, TE
OFF FR ONO  ATTACK ON
>> EVEN THOUGH IT'S POLITICIZER
CHURCHES THAEMO HAVE
WOCHE GOEL OF SITUAT
DONALD TRU
DENIALISM.
YY
IN SAN ANTONIO WHERE THE W KIN F
DISTSTNGER ABOUT T GOING AND H
IT'S
FEARKEAMB,
THEY HAVE   ORFARE SOHEBEARFO O
N K, TS ANORTH A
TH ON WHS FOLKS COVID.
WON'STH THEIOMOTIOSKEPTICISM ALT
TREATMENTS FM COVID E
THEY SEE THA
E IGHT.
S
WHIS MEAOUT CHRISTIA
WHAT DEEP ANYEH AOAORLD YOU ERY
,
TELY
EYE ON THE AND PUSHB
ORRSH MEDIA NOT ALT IT'S TE NS,R
S OF,
THE WAY COVID  WHO CRTCRITICAL
ITE POLATHE DII K THISIND OFN E?
LIKE -- EXCUS,
DISTRUHERE
ATTRACT IN
D RELIOU
AND SAYI LYING TRU YEAH.
>> AND SOMETES
WELIEVERS.
AND THUN ONE THING THIS HAS DON.
EERSD
PASSED AWAT VACC